a Zionist man with his Zionist wife yes
and what are they doing holding guns
these guns are used to perpetrate
genocide a massacre that's what's
happening and on your right is myself
and my
wife one um is a charity organization
that operates on a 100% donation policy
they do great works like providing clean
water food Aid shelter responding to
natural disasters and they do this in
many countries around the world you can
share in the rewards of everything that
they do and offer to the umah by
subscribing to the ongoing sodaka fund
this charity has been around for over 10
years and I've personally known them for
over 10 years I've personally worked
with them for over 10 years and they're
not paying me to do this W but this is a
charity that I trust and I trust in
Allah subhana wa tala and I want you the
benefit and get the most out of your
charity so click on the link below and
act
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshah
this picture that you can see brother
and sisters on the left hand side
brother and sisters is a family of
zionists criminals war criminals holding
a gun a Zionist man with his Zionist
wife yes and what are they doing holding
guns these guns are used to perpetrate
genocide a massacra that's what's
happening and on your right is myself
and my wife we went to a little photo
shoot that we did for the marriage
documentary and alhamdulillah uh the
brother who was taking the photo shoot
um had a few of these weapons around
don't worry it's all legal don't worry
about that it's all legal and I thought
you know let me take some funny pictures
it was in my album and I never thought
the day will come I would find a use for
it and it did today I was scrolling on
Instagram saw this picture and I thought
to myself wow I could remember imagine
brothers and sisters
myself taking this picture and putting
it online I would have the MI5 the MI6
the mi7 mi8 mi9 Mi 10 to whenever on my
doorstep and let me tell you even the
fact that I have this picture would even
be like oh my gosh what is it Etc is it
real oh my God is it going to Jihad yes
but so casually these war criminals who
are carrying out a genocide Massacre and
I said before from the top top down all
of them are singing from the same tune
of Palestinian kids are not innocent and
you can see what they're do by quoting
biblical terms brothers and sisters they
have done this for so long and they have
tried to IM emasculate the Muslim man
from being a real man what is wrong with
a Muslim man legally going to a gun rage
yes in America it's legal yes if it was
in this country I would be there every
day why because it is something think
that every man would do Muslim or nonm
Muslim for that matter but no they want
to make you afraid of doing stuff like
that martial arts boxing uh uh whatever
it is for that matter they have made us
feel as if we cannot do certain stuff
brothers and sisters and this is the aim
and objectives of them and this is the
reason why Muslim men have become so
cowardly and so weak in this element
brothers and sisters it is a time that
we take a stand on this matter and as
Muslim men like my myself personally
I've been doing I do training all day
every day yes I love it it's something
that I love doing yeah but recently I
signed up to I signed up to the
nutrition program and the workout
program of silver back brother ajal may
Allah bless him inallah and I'm planning
on getting ripped and getting bigger why
it's for myself and my well-being not
for anybody else alhamdulillah but as a
man I feel like me sitting down on my
coach uh on my sofa eating Crips and
chocolate and letting the world go by is
not what we should do brothers and
sisters we need to understand this we
all have a d duty to play and as men we
need to take our responsibility back
like Allah says in the Quran men are the
maintainers and prot a woman but this
picture shows you the utter double
standards and hypocrisy of the Western
World yes they can so casually knowing
take these pictures just imagine for a
second if a Muslim nation was committing
atrocities against the Christians or the
Hindus or the Jewish the Jewish
Community or whatever for that matter
and I casually said on my wedding day I
am holding an AK-47 or this that or
whatever for that matter there will be
absolute chaos but you can see one rule
for them and another another rule for us
that's why the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said this world is a prison for
the believer because we have to be
tested and tri brother and sisters but
for the disbeliever yes it is like Jenna
and let them have their Jenna brothers
and sisters yes because on the day of
judgment not the icj not the world
leaders you saw not even Muslim leaders
none of them are there for the Gins the
Palestinians none of them none none zero
so much so South Africa yes a non-muslim
nation has gone to the icj and you've
seen what the outcomes are okay you can
see what the outcomes are so let them
have their couple of minutes of
enjoyment because if you calculate you
could never divide Infinity by by a
finite time of 60 70 years brothers and
sisters what our brothers and sisters
going in Gaza Palestine what what we're
going through the test and trials in
this life it is worth it how because
eternally eternally just imagine for a
second eternity there's it's going to be
an eternity No Beginning No End eternity
sorry eternity of bliss with the trials
and tribulations we're going to go
through and with a permission of Allah
subhana tala as long as we die on I
wanted to bring this to your attention
guys because it just shows the utter
double standards and hypocrisy and let
me tell you something I won't be
surprised if they use this picture of me
and my wife on Daily Mail and this that
islamist Jihadi with his AK-47 brothers
and sisters this is what they would do
alhamdulillah that's all I'm going to
say and you can see the UT hypocrisy one
thing before I go brother and sisters
please please please donate to the
ongoing Saka fund of one um inshallah
which is very very important why it is a
tool a vehicle that is helping 10 plus
countries that are in dire need so it is
an opportunity for you for the first
time ever that you do a donation and it
helps multiple places rather than going
to one specific Place brother and sister
inshallah the link in the description
box below brothers and sisters that's
all I want to say inshallah may Allah
bless you you guys inah it was a uh
shoot that me and my wife took it was a
funny one uh with different poses but
alhamdulillah I think this was my
favorite pose with my wife brothers and
sisters may Allah subhana T preserve you
guys inshallah and Men start to act like
men inshallah do not let the inferior
complex of the western world and the
hypocrisy make you feel that you cannot
go out there and do what they what not
what they're doing because our religion
doesn't teach that but to go there get
fit look after yourself of what you eat
ald if you live in America go to gun
regions to ex
absolutely nothing wrong so that's all I
have to say in brother and sisters till
next
time